hi i will be talking about quantum
versus randomized communication
complexity with efficient players
this is based on a joint work with rand
raj and avishaital
the setting is communication complexity
there is a function that takes as input
to binary string
and outputs a bit this function may be
partial
which means that it is defined on a
subset of points or it may be totaled
which means that it is defined on all
points
there are two parties alice and bob
alice gets one of the inputs and bob
gets the other input
their goal is to compute this function
to do so they need to exchange messages
with each other
and their goal is to minimize the amount
of communication that is the number of
bits that they exchange
one simple protocol is to have alice
send her entire input to bob
or bob send his entire input to alice
this costs m
or n bits of communication so by a small
cost protocol we mean a protocol that
does much better than this
that is its cost is poly logarithmic in
m and n
this is the general setting of
communication complexity
let us see a few different models of
communication
in the classical randomized setting
alice and bob share
public random coins which they can toss
arbitrarily many times
and their goal is to compute f x y with
probability at least
2 3 while minimizing the worst case
amount of communication
in the quantum setting there are two
differences the first is that alice and
bob
share epr pairs the second is that they
can exchange qubits
this is an inherently probabilistic
model and as before their goal is to
compute f
x y with probability at least two-thirds
while minimizing the number of qubits
that they exchange
we will also be interested in the number
of rounds of a communication protocol
in two-way communication alice and bob
can interact with each other
in one way communication alice sends a
message to bob
and bob must decide whether the function
is zero or one
in simultaneous communication alice and
bob do not talk to each other
instead there is a third party a referee
charlie to whom both alice and bob
send messages charlie upon receiving the
messages from alice and bob
needs to declare whether the function is
0 or 1.
sometimes we allow alice and bob to
share epr pairs
sometimes we don't it depends on the
model
these are successively weaker models of
communication
that is there are functions that are
easy in the two-way model
but hard in the one-way model similarly
there are functions that are easy in the
one-way model
but hard in the simultaneous model
now that i've introduced the relevant
communication models
let us state the main problem of
interest
is there a communication problem that
has a small cost quantum protocol
but no small cost classical protocol
is there a function that is easy to
communicate when you can exchange
qubits but hard when you can only
exchange classical bits
so does quantum provide advantage in the
world of communication complexity
for total functions we don't know the
answer it could very well be
that every quantum protocol for a total
function can be converted into a
classical protocol
with minimal overhead this is a major
open question
for partial functions on the other hand
there is a long line of research
spanning over 20 years
all of which demonstrates that quantum
communication can
provide more power that is quantum
communication can provide exponential
advantages over classical communication
for partial functions the first
such result was established by moorman
cleveland winterson
who showed that in the zero error
setting when we want to answer correctly
with probability one
there are partial functions that are
easy in the quantum simultaneous model
but exponentially harder in the
classical two-way model
this suggests that a rather weak model
of quantum communication
can exponentially outperform a rather
powerful classical model of
communication
in the bounded error setting when we
want to answer correctly with probably
at least
2 3 the first such result was
shown by ran raj he showed that quantum
2a can exponentially outperform
randomized
2a a similar result was shown for
quantum one-way versus randomized
one-way
this was strengthened to a separation
between quantum one-way and randomized
two-way
finally the state-of-the-art separation
is between quantum simultaneous where
alice and bob share entanglement
and randomized 2a let us take a closer
look at this result
the state of the art result is due to
govindski
he shows that there is a partial
function which has a small cost
quantum simultaneous protocol when alice
and bob share a few epr pairs
however there is no randomized protocol
of small cost regardless of the number
of rounds
this result essentially subsumes most of
the prior separations
on bounded error quantum versus bonded
error classical
secondly it demonstrates that a rather
weak model of quantum communication
can exponentially outperform a rather
powerful model of
classical communication
one drawback of this result in the
context of our work
is that the quantum protocol is not
efficient
we say that a quantum protocol is
efficient if it can be implemented by a
quantum circuit
of small size with oracle access to the
inputs
this means two things the first is that
the amount of post-processing and
pre-processing done by the players
is not too much in comparison to the
size of the messages that they send
that is everything that alice bob and
charlie do
can be implemented by quantum circuits
of poly logarithmic
size secondly the oracle access to the
inputs
just means that alice and bob don't need
to read their input bit by bit
they can make a few queries to their
input in superposition
and still be able to execute the
protocol
in govind's case result the quantum
protocol is not efficient
because the referee has to do in many
measurements one after the other
our result addresses this aspect
be sure that there is a partial function
which has an efficient
small cost quantum simultaneous protocol
when alice and bob share a few epr pairs
however there is no randomized protocol
of small cost
regardless of the number of rounds our
parameters are slightly weaker than
kavinsky's result
but the important difference is that the
quantum protocol in
our result is efficient this means
that everything that alice bob and
charlie do can be implemented by
circuits of
small size with oracle access to the
input
in other words we qualitatively recover
govinski's separation
between quantum simultaneous and
randomized two-way
furthermore our separation has the
property that the quantum protocol is
efficient
that is the actions of all players can
be implemented by circuits of
small size with oracle access to the
inputs
what did we know about efficient
separations
to the best of our knowledge this has
not been explicitly addressed
in the setting of quantum versus
classical separation
in most of the previous separations the
quantum parties seem to be inefficient
and they're inefficient in many
different ways one is that the referee
has to do a lot of
host processing this is the case in
govinsky's result
another reason is the players need to
make multiple probes into the input
this is the case for most of the other
separations that i mentioned
nevertheless we did have an efficient
separation prior to this work
this was between quantum two-way and
randomized two-way
this is obtained by taking the existent
efficient separations in the query
complexity world
and lifting them to communication
complexity using the query to
communication lifting theorems
the reason this only gives us an
efficient separation between two-way
quantum and two-way randomized
is that the gadgets used in these
lifting theorems
seem to introduce two new rounds into
the communication protocol
our result unites these two lines of
work we recover the state-of-the-art
result
using quantum protocols where all the
parties are efficient
secondly we provide a new lower bound
technique for randomized communication
complexity
based on fourier analytic techniques
from these two works
the first is the polarizing random walks
result of shadow padilla etta
the second is the oracle separation
result of bqp
and ph
now that i have introduced our results
let me demonstrate the function for
which our separation holds
our function is based on the hadamard
matrix
so let capital n b2 to the little end
the hadamard matrix of size capital n by
capital n
is defined as follows each row and
column
can be indexed by a bit string of length
little n
let a and b be bit strings of length
little n
the a comma b entry is plus or minus 1
over square root capital n
the sign is plus if the inner product
between the row and the column is 0 mod
2
and the sign is minus if the inner
product between the row and column is 1
mod 2.
here is an example of a 2 by 2 hadamard
matrix the hadamard matrix is a unitary
matrix
it has close connections with the
fourier transform so for instance
if you take the truth table of a
function and apply the hadamard matrix
what you get is the truth table of the
fourier transform of the function
up to some normalization factor we are
now ready to define the correlation of a
vector
the correlation of a vector is
essentially the inner product between
the second half of the vector
and the hadamard transform of the first
half up to some normalization
in other words it measures the
correlation between the second half of
the vector
and the fourier transform of the first
half
up to normalization
the correlation function was first
introduced by aaronson
who showed that estimating the
correlation of a vector
is easy when you have quantum query
access to the entries of the vector
but is difficult when you only have
classical query access
the correlation function has thus
already been used to separate
quantum and classical in the query
complexity world
we show a separation in the
communication complexity world
for convenience our inputs are now from
minus 1 1 instead of
0 1 and we use the pointwise product
instead of xor our problem is as follows
the correlation communication problem
alice gets x bob gets y their goal
is to find out if x x or y has high
correlation
or whether it has low correlation where
this high
and low differ by roughly 1 over log n
where n
is roughly the input size if you are
familiar with the lifting literature
this is a lift of the correlation query
problem with xor as the gadget
our main separation is for this function
that is we show that this function has
an efficient
quantum simultaneous protocol of small
cost when alice and bob share a few epr
pairs
however this function has no randomized
protocol of small cost
regardless of the number of rounds
this is our main theorem in the next 10
minutes or so
i will describe a proof of this main
theorem the quantum upper bound
essentially follows
from existing work we will instead focus
on
the proof of the randomized lower bound
by the yahoo's minmax principle it
suffices to produce two distributions
one on the yes instances of the
formulation problem and one on the no
instances
such that no deterministic protocols of
small cost can distinguish them with
considerable advantage
we now demonstrate our heart
distributions to do so we make use of
the forrelation distribution
as defined in the oracle separation
result of raj and tal
it's not too important what this
distribution is for the rest of the talk
but to have a picture in mind the
distribution is as follows
in the first step we sample a random
gaussian vector
where each entry has mean 0 and variance
epsilon
furthermore the second half is exactly
the hadamard transform of the first half
this vector is in some sense as for
related as can be
in the second step we perform a
randomized rounding of
z to get a boolean vector
the first thing that raj and tal show is
that a vector sampled from
this distribution has high correlation
on expectation
for now let us imagine that this holds
with high probability
we now define our heart distributions
for the communication problem
for the no instances a string z is
sampled
uniformly at random whereas for the yes
instances
z is sampled from the correlation
distribution
now in both cases a string x is sampled
uniformly at random
alice gets x bob gets x x or
z note that the distribution of no
instances
is the following distribution alice and
bob get two uniformly random strings
that are independent of
each other the distribution of yes
instances
is as follows alice and bob get two
uniformly random strings
conditioned on their xor being drawn
from the correlation distribution
note that when two strings are sampled
uniformly at random independently
their xor is also uniformly random
strings and
it has low correlation with high
probability intuitively speaking but
this can be formalized
on the other hand for the distribution
on yes instances the xor is distributed
according to the correlation
distribution
which i just mentioned has high
formulation
so these are valid hard distributions
and our main theorem is that
deterministic protocols of
small cost cannot distinguish these two
distributions with considerable
advantage
that is for all deterministic protocols
of cost at most c
their advantage in distinguishing these
two distributions is at most c
square over square root n in other words
when the cost is less than n to the one
fourth
the advantage in distinguishing these
two distributions is really small
in the next few minutes i will describe
an overview of the proof of this theorem
so our goal is to show that for
deterministic protocols of cost
at most c their advantage in
distinguishing these two distributions
is at most
c square over square root n every
protocol of cost c
can be broken up into two to see many
rectangles
this is a standard argument in
communication complexity
so it surfaces to show that rectangles
that are not too small
cannot distinguish these two
distributions that is
we want to show that for sets a and b
whose measure is roughly 2 to the minus
c
the advantage of the rectangle indicator
a times indicator b
in distinguishing these two
distributions is at most this quantity
which is c square over square root n
times 1
over 2 to the c
if we could prove this then by adding up
this inequality over all rectangles in
the partition we will get our desired
inequality
so now our goal is to show this
inequality
we introduce an important simplification
here which is the convolution of
functions the convolution of indicator
and indicator b
is denoted by indicator a star indicator
b
it's defined exactly as shown in this
equation
note that this quantity appears in both
of these terms
so we can substitute this back and
rewrite our goal as
follows so now our goal is to show
that the function indicator a star
indicator b has
similar expectations under the uniform
distribution and
under the formulation distribution
how do we go about showing this we make
use of existing
results
it follows from the works of chatopathy
and raj and tal
that if you want to show that a certain
function can't distinguish between the
uniform distribution and
the correlation distribution it suffices
to prove a
level 2 fourier bound on this function
to be more precise
we need a nice family of boolean
functions
this nice is some technical condition
which is closed under restrictions
this is satisfied by most of the
functions that you could think of that
are built out of
small cost protocols small cost decision
trees and so on
but let us just ignore this condition
for now this theorem says
if that for all functions in your family
the level two fourier mass
is at most alpha then the advantage that
this function family has
in distinguishing the uniform
distribution from the correlation
distribution
is at most alpha over square root n
that is if any nice family of boolean
functions has
small level 2 fourier mass it cannot
distinguish between the uniform
distribution
and a distribution built out of weakly
correlated gaussians
we make use of this result as follows so
our goal was to show
that indicator a star indicator b cannot
distinguish between the uniform
distribution
and a distribution built out of weakly
correlated gaussians
we reduce this to showing a bound on the
level 2 fourier mass of indicator a
star indicator b
so now our goal is to just prove this
fourier bound
how do we prove this fourier bound
the first observation is that the
fourier coefficients of the convolution
are the product of fourier coefficients
using this we can simplify the
expression for the level to mass
as follows we now apply cauchy schwartz
to obtain this
we now bound each of these terms in this
inequality
as follows we use the level k
inequalities
this appears as an application of hyper
contractivity in ryan odonnell's book
this allows us to bound the sum of
squares of level two fourier
coefficients
of an indicator function of a subset in
terms of the measure of the subset
this inequality and its variance have
been used in most of the previous
separations on quantum versus classical
communication complexity
so it is not surprising that it shows up
in our work as well
substituting this inequality in our
previous inequality we get exactly what
we want
this concludes the proof of the level 2
fourier bound
to summarize what we did we considered
this function f of z
which is obtained by taking a
convolution of low cost communication
protocols
we bounded the level two fourier mass of
that function and
we use existing works to conclude that
this function cannot distinguish
between the uniform distribution and the
correlation distribution
with considerable advantage and these
two facts together
gave us the lower bound on the
communication complexity
let me conclude by mentioning some open
questions
the first is that can we improve the
lower bound to omega square root n
we believe that this is the correct
lower bond for the function that we
defined earlier
to prove this it would suffice to prove
a level two fourier bound of order c
on this function f of z
the other direction is to prove
separations between other models of
communication complexity
for example we could weaken the model of
quantum
for example quantum simultaneous without
entanglement
or we could prove advantages against
stronger classical
models this concludes my talk
thank you for watching